maintenant ces nouveaux corps ce n'est
plus qu'une ombre au fisc les noms des
grades la hiérarchie l'organisation et
on va commencer par le chef qui
intéressait on a remonté encore chez
nous les patrons maintenant maintenant
c'est nous l'agencé nous qui décidons
je sens que ça va pas beaucoup m'ont dit
tu vas devoir faire un choix john ça
fait 30 ans que j'attends c'est si
absurde que ça d'avoir envie voir son
fils john va venir à nous ce n'est
qu'une question de temps
il est en train de se transformer ne
faut surtout pas précipiter les choses
la mère fait partie d'une bande de gens
très bizarre qui veut contrôler le monde
le croyant hypnose pour qu'il réponde à
vent glacial et dévastateur sur le monde
a fait 500 gens qu'on attend ça
je voulais vérifier si tu étais capable
de tuer quelqu'un si on pouvait éviter
de mal énervé c'est moi que j'allais
derrière ton père la seule part
d'humanité que tu as toi me suis demandé
si j'ai vraiment envie de continuer
j'aime pas pourquoi je suis avec toi je
sais pas ce que supporte toi tu dois te
botter [ __ ] vous dire comment on ne
sous estime pas qui tu as en face
ouais vous n'êtes pas en position de
négocier quoi je ne sais pas ce qu'il
voulait attaquer victoire mais c'était
pas non en général quand ça attaque si
machin n'y a pas de survivant sow est
super héros là est terminée cette vie
tout le monde s'en fout qu'il soit
honnête exemple est bouleversée par
l'incroyable insouciance avec laquelle
tu es à mysteries vers le gouffre tout
ce qu'il décide est même directement
leurs pertes c'est presque suicide
quoi quoi hein
j'ai toujours été impressionné par les
supérieurs ma femme est partie avec un
super héros je vais pas vous parler de
ma vie
le
mon
sans ses fidèles ce sens epinal je ne
sais pas l'ambiance je vous assure ça
file de l'antre à 3,407 vie d'ascète
village